on the proposal for a recommendation on  minimum income  it aims to tackle social exclusion by  making sure that EU countries have  accessible and adequate social safety  nets in place following an active  inclusion approach and including through  minimum income schemes  so safety nets help to reduce social  inequalities within member states they  help boost employment by contributing to  labor market integration for those who  can work  uh minimum income schemes to strike the  right balance between alleviating  poverty providing sufficient incentives  and supporting people to pre-integrate  in society and labor markets they should  be sustainable in terms of their  budgetary costs  today's recommendation will help to  reach the eu's 2030 targets of reducing  a number of people in poverty and social  exclusion and or boosting employment